well it didn't take long Donald Trump's
second muslim-majority country
immigration ban has been blocked again
first by a judge in Hawaii and then by a
judge in Maryland it was just about to
go into effect in federal judges Derek
Watson and Theodore Trang blocked the
ban on new visa approvals for people
from the updated list the initial list
of seven countries pared down to six
muslim-majority countries why was this
one blocked glad you asked a judge cited
Donald Trump's campaign statements that
his intent here is to keep Muslim people
out of the country that means based on
religious identification that is
discriminatory and this has caused
concern among supporters of this bill
saying wait a second hold on hold on how
can a judge consider something that
Trump said during the campaign as
context for whether the ban is
discriminatory there's legal precedent
for this if you look at McCreary County
versus the ACLU that led to a Court
opinion stating quote Court's precedents
sensibly forbid an observer to turn a
blind eye to the context in which the
policy arose of course Donald Trump
speaking yesterday at a rally in
Nashville Tennessee said that the travel
restrictions were needed to protect
Americans from radical Islamic
terrorists and vowed to take the case
all the way to the Supreme Court of
course Nationals from the countries on
the list haven't actually attacked us so
at face value the ban itself seems to
reject logic and reason and the likely
appeals process here will be first to
the same san francisco court that
rejected the first ban and ultimately if
indeed we see it appealed to this level
to the supreme court this is temporary
Pat this is a temporary blocking of
Trump's order not a permanent one judges
are saying that based on their initial
understanding it appears that this would
violate the constitutional and be
discriminatory so they're suspending the
90-day implementation but there's still
an uphill battle here for the permanent
this band I was honestly rather
surprised that this got struck down
because even though I thought it was
terrible policy I thought that it was
constitutional and within the rights of
the executive branch right because it
seemed to get rid of the original
provisions from the first travel ban
that made that one unconstitutional
right Christians were no longer
prioritized over Muslims and it seemed
to open the door to allow green card
holders back into the country so I
thought with those changes it would have
been just fine I don't disagree with you
I mean in other words based on the
initial reasons that it was shut down
that they quote shut the whole thing
down I thought that this one wouldn't be
blocked for the same reasons and we were
correct about that but different reasons
given this time for why this one is
being blocked now on what basis do
opponents claim that the travel via
travel ban violates the Constitution or
other law First Amendment Fifth
Amendment and the u.s. immigration and
national act it's one of the in one of
the articles I read about this a
defender of the order from Donald
Trump's administration or Justice
Department said hey guys this isn't
discriminatory against Muslims because
it doesn't affect 100% of Muslims only
some Muslims have you ever heard of a
more flaccid and weak defense any law
that doesn't impact all members of a
protected class is not discriminatory
and the opinion from the Hawaii Court
actually addressed this saying that it's
illogical that the illogic of the
government's contention on this is
palpable the notion that one can
demonstrate animus toward any group of
people only by targeting them all at
once is fundamentally flawed how bad
will this be for Trump will people see
it as a total failure well many people
say Trump was a victim of evil liberal
activist judges what's clear is that
this is embarrassingly bad if you
understand what the court said because
the court said three things that if you
if you get it you should be embarrassed
if you're a supporter of this ban number
one that Donald Trump's words matter
what he said is being considered in
evaluating the real and true goal of
this travel ban that's really bad for
Trump number two the ruling rejects the
notion
that something is only discriminatory if
100 percent of the target demographic or
group is impacted and legally that's
huge and number three if you look at the
legal language in in very succinct and
and and concise legal language what
these judges said is this entire thing
as harebrained and the arguments from
the Trump administration make no sense
and perhaps not surprisingly he
continues to shoot himself in the foot
yeah because they had another one of
these post election campaign rallies
yesterday in Nashville and he called
this new ban a watered down version of
the original one yeah so now that we
know that his words matter in
determining precedent in these cases I
mean how is the appeal going to go in
his favor if he's already admitted that
yeah he's basically saying this is just
another version of the thing that's
already been rejected multiple times by
courts